hello and welcome to the last airbender
V logs we are talking about episode 2
the Avatar returns and the funny thing
is on the last one I was saying how the
first episode while I liked it it wasn't
like you know gripping me like I had to
see the next episode I wanted to see it
but I didn't have to see it uh this is
the episode where that happens this is
the episode where I thought it really
kind of gets fun and you sort of see the
cool things they can do with the powers
and the story sort of gets sort of fixed
and stuff like that so uh this one was a
lot of fun uh what sort of if you hear
thunder by the way it's raining um
what grabbed me about it too is that
outsourcing before like the humor was a
little off and in some scenes it still
kind of is that's a little weird and
awkward but what I like about a lot is
that the kid characters are still
essentially kids and like this Aang
character the the avatar in it it's
extremely likable and I like that they
make him very wide-eyed very innocent
stuff and he knows there's this
responsibility based not is so far
didn't seem like he straight up running
away from it because he seems to have a
good ethics and good morals and he wants
to help out um the other thing too a
character that when I first saw him my
god JJ I hope this kid isn't annoying
and that's the brother character um and
he steps up in this episode too there's
a scene where like this giant submarine
is coming right at him and he's standing
his ground on the village a terrifying
this thing is gonna come it's gonna
crush him but the snow moves him back so
he doesn't quite get crushed uh
strategically not smart move but I
really like the fact that he was gonna
stick there he was gonna stand his
ground and even when he tries to fight
the prince character and comedic lessor
gets his ass handed to him uh it shows
he really does have sort of this brave
side that you know he's a goof up and
he's a complainer but he will stand up
for him so I really liked that I thought
that was really cool um you know sir
gives him much more likability instead
of just being like just sort of a comic
relief so I really like that a lot um
and this one we finally get some of the
action coming through this is where the
avatar is that he's captured by the
prince and he has to escape and this
show is so good in this I very much
connect us or like that Japanese side
where they can really come up with
creative fight sequences and just some
great scenes of you know just him in a
room and the fire prince and the avatar
with his wind bending what they could do
to one another just the objects in the
room you know just using like the
mattress from the bed slamming against
him and taking him and throwing him up
and down and using the fire the one to
put out the fire and stuff a lot of fun
lot of creativity um and and I like the
fact the quests were begun too with the
sister and the brother gonna find the
avatar it looks like they're going to um
you know sir figure out what his
backstory is as well am I gonna teach
her how to waterbend and then he's gonna
sort discover his true potential it's it
now seems like it's going and part of
that could very well be because maybe
there is just something to you need an
hour because like before I was talking
about shows like Lost and Game of
Thrones and stuff that you know on the
first episode they get you hooked but
they had an hour and now that this these
two episodes are combined together I do
really want to see the next episode I
wanna know what's going to happen even
if I didn't have to do these V logs I
would really want to know what's gonna
happen next and again I like the fact
that even by the end of this the the kid
the avatar I serve knows this wait now
that he has to carry and he has this
great responsibility but he still wants
to travel to see the great sights in
goof-off and I like how in the opening
it seems like they set the tone pretty
well in this opening to I don't know if
the intros change each time but um well
the sister is giving the backstory of
everything that's going on and she talks
about Aang you know the great last
airbender you know who I'm sure is going
to be our hero but kind of has a bit of
learning to do and just seeing him
laughing while I'm that ball of air and
then slamming into a wall I mean that's
that's a very likable character and
that's a character that you want to
follow because you know he isn't totally
absent-minded you know he's not just
a goofball you know that he's a kid and
he acts very much like a kid I like that
a lot I like the fact that these are you
know even the prince is still very much
a teenager and I really like the fact
that they have them do very adult stuff
very grown-up stuff but they still
acknowledge their age and they still
they act like people of that age being
forced to go into tough situations
situations where they're going to be
really challenged and I'm liking that a
lot you know remind me a little bit of
the Hunger Games where if I was to watch
this uh if this was to be given to me as
hey this is an adult show I might have a
few more issues with it but the fact
that it's marketed towards kids and a
lot of people again say oh what there
shouldn't be a difference kid should be
a treated as a treat as adults no there
is a difference but kids should not
always be talked down to and their
intelligence shouldn't be insulted it
should be addressed at the proper stage
of their age that they're at and I think
this show does that and it does actually
it's a very good balance of service good
action this good drama but sort of this
light-hearted comedy that comes from
their age and what they're being put
into so I like that a lot
again not all the comedy works but
that's nitpicking you know just are the
trade-off you do with kid shows so uh
episode 2 has gotten really fun and it's
nice to see the Buffalo finally fly and
again like the angles that they get
again I serve connect this to the
Japanese element of the animation
there's a scene where like Aang is
hanging off the submarine or or he's
almost gonna fall off and he sort of
swings like this trying to get his
balance back and you really sort of feel
you can go like that come on lean back
lean back uh something about the angles
that they get in the style animation
even though I know technically it's
American animation but they're borrowing
a lot from Japanese animation and they
just get really good angles a lot of the
angles inside the ship anytime they go
inside the ship there's always gonna be
great angles I don't know what I don't
know why the best angles are in that
ship but they always get some really
great one some great Dutch angles wide
angles all sorts of great stuff and it
really gives you a sense like you're
really there
more than just creating a world it
creates you know it it creates a room I
know it sounds strange but there's
something to creating a world and also
creating a room and you can believe
you're in a world but not necessarily in
the room and vice versa so I like the
fact they seem to have both of them down
they had this world down and they also
had the very simple element of just
being you know in a room I know it
sounds really really strange but you'd
be surprised how many people can't pull
that off um you know I love Laura the
Rings you know a lot of the time it's
like okay well here's middle-earth and
everything is so incredible so fantastic
that you kind of have a hard time
believing you're really there or or the
Lucas stuff the George Lucas prequels
and stuff it fell victim to that a lot
there's just too much going on uh and I
thought they did a good job job gave me
this idea of space again just the fight
that they had with the firebender prince
on the Airbender in that room you really
felt like those materials you know we're
physically hitting that guy and it made
the action so much more enjoyable and
you know like a better word realistic
like you were there experiencing it and
watching it so I like that I like that
really has the respect for its
environment and it's space that's
probably why I'm looking for an
environment in space or the words I'm
looking for so uh so - I like a great
deal and I can't wait to see you where
it goes from now now that like the
adventure is really starting so uh uh
yeah I'm really excited about it I don't
know why the brother sent the Airbender
away if he was probably gonna be the
only thing to defend him against the
fire people but whatever he came back
came back so uh yeah I'm looking forward
to the next episode second one was
really good and I'm hype man I wanna see
where it goes